anonimo discreto conferencial e vou levá
lo a caminhar por um território bastante
semifinal o uso que é o território da
sexualidade
trago aqui algumas mensagens a companhia
alan e everaldo decidir retirar o leite
do peito e deixar pingar no órgão
genital do bebê
o torna gostoso na vida sexual quando
este for adulto
se for verdade que em um e gostoso já
sabe a mãe nos boletins órgão genital
fundador da pele mais uma noite é
verdade que uma mulher durante o parto
não pode abrir a boca
silva se o fizer corre o risco de matar
o bebê
imagina num momento de dor do parto
excessiva a mulher não puderam abrir a
boca gritar esbravejar a acusar o marido
com muitas fazem metade dessa sala não
teria sido montadas mulher chora chora
na hora do parto está com mais uma bola
na mão em uma mulher grávida que corre
como ovo cozido e da luz sem a bebé sem
cabelo esse bebê pode vir a ter cabelo
pintado nós teríamos carecas a vida toda
nós temos bastante de mensagens com
estas não só comércio de bens também
algumas com um teor mais fisiológicos
tons mais biológicas como por exemplo o
meu pensamento que não será que você
fazer as raparigas
lembro de uma rapariga escreveu a dizer
eu tenho 15 anos não me sinto próximo
próprio apronta sexualmente ou lembrar
tem 17
os pais dele não estava em casa e ele
diz que não passa de hoje o que eu faço
tem que ser o josé hoje eu não estou
pronto e nós temos que responder naquele
momento porque nós nos tornemos não
responderemos de forma correta naquele
momento esta rapariga dias seguintes à
grávida uma semana depois a grávida
então esse é o tipo de mensagem que nós
recebemos na plataforma traz à cena é em
média 250 a 300 por semana e isso quase
seis raparigas de docentes vão
escrevendo convencido estão de lugar
como a noite e não é má não entre na
verdade é um
a equipe de conselheiros de enfermeiros
que vai respondendo
e isso nos leva a pensar num paradoxo
que é de que forma em que medida é que
esta docente prefere abrir mão do espaço
considerado seguro tradicionalmente
seguro como a família à escola os amigos
não é para fazer consultas sobre
sexualidade e vai buscar plataformas
como a mãe que existem muitas para tirar
essas dúvidas que o que leva 200 sente
mais confortável com amamente como a
rapariga distância não é que ele não
conhece e eu sempre confortável fazer
perguntas das mais íntimas mais privadas
pode ser pode ser que o fato de nós
vivenciamos a nossa sexualidade de forma
bastante criativa esteja na origem desse
conforto esteja na origem da forma como
essas plataformas a de comunicação hoje
em dia se tornem espaços seguros mais
duras mas o que distingue estes dois
passos
por um lado eu acho que o tipo de
plataformas como a plataforma tua cena
mas não muito frança é que elas oferecem
um diálogo franco e alberto construtivos
em julgamentos são pessoas preparadas
para receber todo tipo de questões não é
principalmente aquelas culturalmente
digamos urbanos que vem bastante
carregadas de preconceitos julgamentos
de percepções negativas sobre a
sexualidade são também plataformas ou
são sopas preparadas não é pra falar de
forma franca de forma aberta em de
alguma forma isso contra lixo nos
espaços de socialização tradicionais que
nós temos como as nossas próprias
famílias
nós como país e eu me incluo tem outros
sentem em casa de 11 anos
o que nós fazemos nós controlamos o
diálogo sobre sexualidade mas não
falaram sobre sexualidade com os nossos
filhos nos omitimos não é a nossa
própria consciência sobre o cerco sobre
sexualidade como se ela não existisse o
que nós fazemos procuramos controlar o
acesso à informação de adolescentes
acesso aos conteúdos sobre sexualidade
nós procuramos a moldá los de definir e
influenciar as suas escolhas sobre
sexualidade às suas práticas sobre
sexualidade e mais do que isso nós
procuramos influenciar as suas escolhas
em termos de identidade sexual não
acredito que ele seja heterossexual
eles não podem ser homossexuais eles não
podem ser traz sexual eles não podem ser
bissexuais e essa influência toda esse
controle do acaba tendo as suas
consequências e eu vejo consequências
diferentes níveis a nível familiar a
todas aquelas consequências com a a por
exemplo dificilmente o fato de os
dirigentes não terem acesso à informação
sobre sexualidade eles vão estar esta
informação espaços menos seguros em
canais menos seguros
eles vão buscar essa informação e
através de junho em amigos em redes
sociais não estão informadas máquina de
oferecem formação sólida sobre
sexualidade mas uma outra consequência é
que eles vão também adotar completamente
do lixo porque o fato não ter
informações suficientemente sólidas e
corretas sobre sexualidade
eles vão absorver com mais facilidade do
que for colocado adiante
então eu acho que essas são algumas das
consequências sem falar nos
comportamentos perversos sobre
sexualidade nos comportamentos de risco
sobre sexualidade mas a consequência
tamanho nível a nível macro nem vou como
país
olhemos por exemplo a questão do hiv e
sida nós recebemos eu recebi com
freqüência perguntas sobre porque é que
depois de 30 20 30 anos de investimento
a sobrar na área do hiv e nós
continuamos a ter taxa de prevalência
altas porque isso acontece não é
e quero estar na área da saúde dessas da
saúde sexual prossegue percebe questiona
muito grande parte do investimento
acontece na área da saúde é problema e
vencida e um pergunto como é que nós
vamos resolver a questão do hiv sida se
sexo é tabu sexualidade é tabu não
podemos falar sobre sexualidade logo o
nosso discurso sobre hiv sida é um
discurso superficial
não é um discurso profundo nós não
falamos de todas aquelas questões sobre
os valores sobre as crenças questões
culturais que estão as associadas
uma comunidade com sexualidade logo de
forma alguma nós vamos poder dialogar
sobre hiv e sida e pior do que isso
temos uma certa urgência em resolver a
questão e essa urgência leva no jardim
há programas sem exagero nós vamos 12
anos 15 anos até começarmos a construir
a nossa
a nossa percepção sobre a nossa própria
sexualidade relação conosco mesmo outros
levamos 15 ante 30 anos né
vamos transformando ela vamos já
registados nos adaptando
então vamos absorver preferência sobre
sexualidade e vão construindo e vamos
usando para moldar a forma como nós
lidamos com com a nossa sexualidade o
que acontece é que com este programa de
desenvolvimento na área da saúde
nós queremos que em uma conversa de uma
hora palestras sessões de diálogos a
gente possa a gente construa não é todo
um manancial de informação do valor de
crenças e mitos sobre sexualidade e é
praticamente impossível e continuamos a
fazer isso continuamente sem parar pra
pensar na singularidade de cada
indivíduo sem parar e pensar na forma
com uma cultura tinha língua de cada
indivíduo influencia as suas opções
sexuais
a socialização deste domingo em
influenciar a forma como vai vivenciar a
sua sexualidade
então eu acho que pra terminar eu diria
que nós temos algumas opções e muitos
são jovens nesta sala não tem filhos
mas nós temos as opções da opção de
falar abertamente sobre sexualidade
nós temos a opção de criar desconstruir
a justificar este discurso negativo
sobre a sexualidade não é
temos a opção de passar a partilhar mais
informação mais conteúdos sobre
sexualidade com os docentes para que
eles possam tomar decisões mais
informadas para que eles possam ter
comportamentos de menor risco e nesse de
algo nós precisamos considerar essa
singularidade de cada um de nós é cada
um de nós não somos nós vamos ser sim
sexuados nas semanas
ah ah ah todos nós não é é a sexualidade
é um dos alvos
mas ela também a singulares ela será
singular é de muita pretensão
procurá-los desenvolver e implementar a
mensagem de algo que sirvam para todos
nós
nós somos singulares significa essa
singularidade tem que ser considerada na
forma como o diálogo sobre a sexualidade
acontece é dispendioso exige muitos
recursos principalmente financeiras mas
é possível
por outro lado a eu acho que é
importante se considerarmos a nossa
diversidade cultural
quando pensarmos em termos macro como
país o que nós fazemos é desenvolver
programas funcionam para todo o país
esquecemos para cada 200 quilômetros
neste país temos uma língua hoje aqui
falar de jogar no ataque a 200 km de
falarmos longa mas vemos que o lanús arg
neymar falando de bi tonga
mas devemos falar o x a falar dos
maridos a falar de down que significa
significa guitarra língua é uma etnia é
uma cultura são práticas são crenças
específicas associadas essa língua essa
cultura
então significa que a forma de
socialização e de vivência da
sexualidade em cada uma dessas etnias
diferentes
logo os programas têm de ser pensados
também para incorporar essa diversidade
que acontece é que nós não fazemos disso
queremos quando saí fixou e não funciona
então essas são apenas das alguns dos
desafios que nós temos quando falamos de
sexualidade quando queremos desenvolver
programas que possam influenciar o
crescimento de 200 jovens
obrigado
[Aplausos]